kontroverse über grundgesetz artikel
mehrere politiker sind dafür den begriff
rasse zu streichen
schüsse in atlanta in den usa stirbt
wieder ein afroamerikaner durch
polizeigewalt blitze donner und
starkregen unwetter wüten in vielen
teilen deutschlands in bayern müssen 61
wanderer gerettet werden
[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute mit petra
gerster guten abend kommen bei unseren
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag sport
gibt es auch heute wieder mit norbert
lehmann ein stück von mir
weltweit wird derzeit gegen rassismus
demonstriert auch in deutschland wo das
wort rasse sogar in der verfassung steht
dabei gibt es gar keine menschenrassen
sagen biologen alle menschen hätten im
großen und ganzen die gleichen gene nun
diskutiert die politik ob es nicht an
der zeit sei das wort ganz zu streichen
vor allem aber in artikel 3 grundgesetz
dort heißt es bisher niemand darf wegen
seines geschlechts seiner abstammung
seiner rasse seiner sprache seiner
heimat und herkunft seines glaubens
seiner religiösen oder politischen
anschauungen benachteiligt oder
bevorzugt werden
aus berlin berichtet frank buchwald
berliner politiker haben ihn immer vor
augen
artikel 3 des grundgesetzes eingraviert
in eine glaswand mitten im
regierungsviertel
niemand darf diskriminiert werden klar
das wort rasse im gesetzestext aber
stört manche auch die grünen
wenn wir der meinung sind es gibt keine
rassen und jeder sollte der meinung sein
dann sollten wir das grundgesetz adäquat
formulieren und stattdessen sagen es
sollte keine niemand sollte wegen
rassistischer zuschreibung diskriminiert
werden dann haben wir eine klare kante
gegen rassismus ohne uns im russell
begriff unglaubwürdig zu machen
die mütter und väter des grundgesetzes
die den text vor 70 jahren entwarfen
wollten ein zeichen gegen rassismus
setzen
eine lehre aus dem rassenwahn der
nationalsozialisten dem holocaust endete
nach den erfahrungen der nazizeit und
diesem schlimmsten rassismus in der
geschichte überhaupt je gegeben hat
wollen sie das ausdrücklich ausschließen
und da sind sprach auch dem zeitgeist
wie gesagt das völkerrecht sah das zu
der zeit schon vor und sieht es auch
heute noch vor und das unionsrecht auch
aber wenn man das streicht es steht ja
auch abstammung man abwägen der
abstammung diskriminiert werden das
reicht viele in der union argumentieren
das grundgesetz so wie es ist setze
ohnehin schon starke zeichen gegen
rassismus
deshalb halte ich es für eine absolute
schein und symbol debatte wenn wir jetzt
versuchen würden sprach polizeilich
unsere verfassung zu überarbeiten
es ist ein klarer absoluter
diskriminierungsschutz und es sollte
nicht verbessert werden
die justizministerin unterstützt die
änderung und die kanzlerin zeigt sich
offen für eine debatte
das thema dürfte berlin deshalb wohl
noch eine weile beschäftigen
so geht solidarisch unter diesem motto
sind bundesweit tausende menschen auf
die straße gegangen
mit ihrem protest wollen sie ein zeichen
setzen gegen ungerechtigkeit rassismus
und antisemitismus die größte demo war
mit rund 8.000 teilnehmern in berlin am
brandenburger tor bildeten sie einen
neun kilometer lange menschenkette ein
symbolisches band der solidarität die
antirassistischen proteste hatten ihren
ursprung in amerika nach dem tod von
george floyd vor drei wochen jetzt
befeuert ein neuer fall von
polizeigewalt die wut wieder ist ein
afroamerikaner bei einer scheinbar
harmlosen kontrolle ums leben gekommen
getroffen von der kugel eines polizisten
ines trams berichtet eine
alkoholkontrolle die tödlich endet zwei
polizisten überprüfen richard brooks den
alkoholtest besteht der schwarze nicht
bei der festnahme wehrt er sich im
gerangel entwendet er ein
elektroschockgerät als er flieht feuert
er damit auf die beamten einer von ihnen
schießt auf books im krankenhaus
verstirbt der 27 jährige er rannte mit
dem elektroschocker
nach dem gesetz ist das keine tödliche
waffe er hatte also keine tödliche waffe
und dann haben sie geschossen
es folgen proteste am tatort dem
parkplatz eines schnellrestaurants das
wird in brand gesetzt groß ist die wut
auch nach dem rücktritt der
polizeichefin und dem rauswurf des
schießenden polizisten
dies zeigt doch nur was derzeit wirklich
in diesem land passiert
es ist ja nicht nur atlanta und wieder
die frage was muss passieren dass eine
alkoholkontrolle wie die von richard
brooks nicht eskaliert die rufe nach
einer reform der polizei und einer
stärkung von anderen behörden werden
lauter in der nacht stehen soziale
dienste selten zur verfügung wir müssen
polizeiarbeit ganz neu denken und andere
behörden müssen besser ausgestattet und
finanziert werden
erneut endet ein polizeieinsatz gegen
einen schwarzen tödlich amerika kommt
nicht zur ruhe
jetzt der blick auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen für deutschland und da wird
deutlich dass die neue infektion weiter
gesunken sind
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 260 menschen neu
angesteckt gestern waren es noch 330 die
korona waren app des bundes wird
übermorgen vorgestellt und
freigeschaltet ziel ist es smartphone
nutzer zu informieren wenn sie kontakt
zu einer infizierten person hatten
infektionsketten sollen so durchbrochen
werden
die nutzung ist freiwillig alle fragen
zur corona waren app beantworten wir
schon jetzt im netz in der zdf- heute-
app bei der explosion eines tanklasters
im osten chinas sind mindestens 19
menschen ums leben gekommen mehr als 170
wurden verletzt
die wucht der explosion ließ häuser und
fabrikgebäude einstürzen
mehrere fahrzeuge gerieten in brand
hunderte helfer sind im einsatz um
menschen aus den trümmern zu retten
der lkw hatte flüssiggas geladen die
unfallursache ist noch unklar
es ist ein ungemütliches wochenende
jedenfalls was das wetter angeht
regenfluten gewitter hagel alles war
dabei
in weiten teilen des landes richteten
sich die blicke besorgt gen himmel und
es ist noch nicht vorbei wo die unwetter
durchgezogen sind gilt es aufzuräumen
volker wutschik berichtet
mehr als 100 liter pro quadratmeter bei
mühlhausen thüringen fällt der regen an
diesem wochenende heftig vom himmel der
sand auf den straßen ist von den
ackerflächen rundherum das wasser macht
den gang über den bürgersteig zum
abenteuer viel zu sehen
aber das schlimmste kommt noch in der
garage denke ich mal das auto alles und
wie gesagt da keller unten was alles der
heizung alles stritt der regen fließt
einfach nicht ab auch nicht den luther
am barren berge in niedersachsen der ort
ist wie ein trichter das wasser sammelt
sich in der mitte der kleine bach
bedrohlich angeschwollen sandsäcke
werden herbeigeschafft das hat so stark
geregnet inklusive hagel dass man nicht
mehr fahren konnte nichts mehr sehen
konnte also es war schon war schon sehr
extrem ende eines ausflugs im landkreis
garmisch-partenkirchen bringt die
bergwacht 61 wanderer per hubschrauber
ins tal schlamm entwurzelte bäume
der sturm hat in der nacht ganze arbeit
geleistet brücken und wege sind
beschädigt die wanderer saßen auf einer
hütte fest unter ihnen viele jugendliche
eine ungewöhnliche rettungsaktion bei
der niemand verletzt wurde
wir sind aufwacht und dachte steigen ab
und fahren heim und dann hat mir meine
mama zeigt dass wir nicht absteigen
sondern vielleicht ausgeflogen werden
ist das super ganz toll war noch nie
und nun zu dir zum sport und zu dir
aber da gibt es ja in der tischtennis
bundesliga einen neuen deutschen meister
allerdings in erster fc saarbrücken zum
ersten mal übrigens im playoff finale
musste sich titelverteidiger
ochsenhausen mit 1 3 geschlagen geben
mitentscheidend das duell zweier
weltklasse spieler patrick franziska
weltranglisten sechzehnter und hugo
calderaro nummer sechs der welt aus
brasilien mit dem auftaktmatch
das duell der spitzenspieler beider
teams entscheidet der deutsche in fünf
umkämpften sätzen für sich
die führung für saarbrücken nach drei
monaten wettkampfpause auch beim
tischtennis neuerungen keine
seitenwechsel platte und bälle werden
regelmäßig desinfiziert mann des tages
für die saarländer der chinesischen er
gewinnt gleich zwei partien der erste fc
saarbrücken besiegt die ttf ochsenhausen
mit 3 zu 1
so feiert der erste der hauptrunde auch
den sieg im final turnier um die
deutsche mannschaftsmeisterschaft im
ersten sonntagsspiel der
fußball-bundesliga siegt augsburg in
mainz mit 1 0 drei wichtige punkte gegen
den abstieg augsburg weiterhin
dreizehnter mainz bleibt fünfzehnter
jetzt wollt auch in italien und spanien
wieder der ball
nach der langen corona zwangspause in
der primera division zeigen sich
tabellenführer fc barcelona und lionel
messi in glänzender form
barcelona im ersten spiel seit fast 100
tagen gewohnt dominant vidal mit der
gästeführung in der zweiten minute in
der 37
das 2 0 durch brathwaite sein erstes
pflichtspieltor für barca im stadion von
mallorca keine zuschauer im tv nur
virtuelle fans eingeblendet ganz real
und kurios jedoch dieser flitzer nach
dem seitenwechsel in der schlussphase
alba mit dem 13 0 und messi erzielt den
4 0-endstand der argentinier hat nun den
zwölf spielzeiten nacheinander jeweils
mindestens 20 tore erzielt liga-rekord
einfach weltklasse der mann danken
und was macht das wetter morgen scheint
im norden und osten die sonne sonst
werden gewitter mit viel regen erwartet
vor allem im süden mit unwettergefahr
höchstwerte 15 bis 26 grad
in den nächsten tagen ändert sich nur
wenig im nordosten scheint die sonne
sonst ist es unbeständig das war es von
uns mehr gibt es um 21 uhr 45 bei claus
kleber im heute-journal und morgen
erwartet sie christian sievers um 19 uhr
an dieser stelle ihnen noch einen
schönen